hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game it's played in round
three of the 2018 Isle of Man Chas that
comes the tournament international
tournament and I'm sure you're all going
to enjoy it it's how to really attack
the Sicilian defense it's between a
Ramesh Babu program Amanda and Parvati
ah no I don't think any of them need any
additional introduction so I think it's
best if we just dive straight into the
game Prabhu has the white pieces and he
opens with E for as I already mentioned
the Sicilian has been played
we have c5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d4c
captures Knight captures Knight to f6
and not nice to see c3 the open Sicilian
d600 of the g5 the richter rouser
variation now we have e 6 Queen to d2 a6
and now comes castles we had a Bishop to
e7 f3 giving further protection to the
e4 pawn and also preparing if black
decides to Castle kingside which is most
often the case our white wants to start
expanding the King side with the g4 and
h4 we have a queen to c7 buy aghanim
and now comes h4 and now depending on
what black plays even ideas are
capturing on f6 and then already you can
push g4 and have a target on f6 to push
g5 so nice captures on d4 byline of
Queen captures on d4 and now comes the
b5 o donnell starts expanding on the
Queen side as Prague Castle inside we
have Queen to d2 a very nice move you
could also start attacking immediately
with the g4 but then your queen is on d4
and at some point perhaps if black if Y
decides to capture on f6
then black will also have a nice tempo
on the Queen with a bunch of to f6 in
the Queen on d4 so Bravo first goes back
with the Queen Queen to d2 and now we
have
Bishop to b7 King to befall King to b1 a
nice prophylactic move some of you who
mentioned in the comments that I
shouldn't be using the word prophylactic
because it means something other than
what I think it means but you should
definitely google prophylactic and you
will see that it can definite
we'll be used in the chest as a chest
turn and in fact a lot of chest authors
who use it in their books and also it's
a very nice word so here we have castles
and here are moved 13 where a line of
castle that this position was never
before found on the board in any of the
rated games that are available in the
database so this is now a completely new
game and okay we have Knight to e2 a
very nice move by pregnan and ax as if
you start with the g4 immediately then
you have to face before and I'm pretty
sure a lot of you perhaps even had this
exact same position on the board if you
play against the Sicilian and you like
the best of g5 variation then perhaps
you wanted to start attacking
immediately black counter-attacks on the
Queen side with before and now you have
to decide what to do and here you would
most likely spend most of your time
deciding whether you want to go Knight
to a4 or 92 and then you seen I okay
night-night
a4 perhaps better up to c6 I don't like
Knight to a4 perhaps I want to go
nightly - but then what what have I done
so Bravo avoids all of this and he
instead after castles goes Knight to e2
immediately so now before isn't really
all that impressive because you can
simply capture the pawn and black
doesn't really have any good contra play
here even if d5 creating a discovered
attack against the Queen Queen c3 the
knight from e2 is already nicely
guarding c3 so black would have just
blundered upon us okay after Prague was
92 we have rook a to c8 now the alien of
definitely does have some nice pressure
serve at that nice pressure along the C
file we have nice study 409 central
square for progress night also from d4
for the moment the knight is also gives
protection to the c2 pawn rook F to e8
Alana wants to play Knight study son so
he wants this rook to be protecting the
bishop that occupies east 7 and finally
now that there are no more tricky before
ideas Prague Oh does go g4 and okay we
have Knights to d7 Bishop captures on e7
rook captures on e7 and now h5 it's
interesting
there are there are some very nice games
were for example Miguel tall had
positions like this and then he would go
immediately g5 and then after black
would make some move he would
immediately go g6 and it doesn't matter
what black playstyle already started his
attack and now you're playing his game
and although the engine doesn't really
approve this it would be you know black
who's defending and well if you're
someone who enjoys attacking perhaps you
might want to consider ideas like this
perhaps not in this exact same position
but then after black recaptures you can
already play h6 and already you are
threatening to open up your H file and
have a very nice attack so although it
doesn't show promise in this exact is
that exact same position perhaps in some
of your games you might want to consider
the immediate 2g v g6 and if it doesn't
work it doesn't work and okay probably
goes h5 and now we have d5 if your as I
always say if you were able to play d5
in the Sicilian and not feel bad about
it afterwards you're definitely gonna
have a great game as black Braga
plays h6 and now jisuk with g6 closing
up the position on the kingside and now
it's interesting how to continue this
attack by white as if you can't continue
attacking then it's black who's gonna
start attacking you on the queenside and
then of course the black will be better
so Bishop to d3 definitely a move why it
should consider the bishop from d3 will
be giving the further protection to the
c2 1 and then the Queen will be able to
move but first the problem wants to open
up the e-file he plays it captures on d5
we have Bishop captures on d5 and only
now he plays Bishop to d3 Queen to e5
attacking progress knight on d4 and now
comes the Bishop to e4 now the Queen and
rook are protecting the night we have
Bishop captures only four F characters
on e4 and now comes Knight to f6
it's interesting you also might consider
capturing here
but then after g5 this this Queen would
be not very not excellently placed on e4
this rook from H is coming to e1 the
queen is now guarding the g5 pawn and
white would get a lot of activity for
this one
but it's it's definitely playable for
black however a general decides to go
Knight to f6 now he's attacking both
both points and Prabhu has a very nice
idea
he plays rook ht1 and now we have looked
to d7 it's very interesting rook the
knight chapters on g4 doesn't work
because of nice to see six winning the
exchange your rook is under attack and
also your queen here is under attack and
of course if you capture then you're
getting checkmated Queen d8 check King
has a rook has a block and now Queen
captures will be checkmate as the point
is guarding the g7 square so after rook
hd1 interestingly the best idea for
black is actually nice captures on e4
and it's a it's very strange because now
Queen to e3 is no threat against the
knight on e4 because black can't defend
it with f5 and on the other hand after
Knight captures on name for Queen to b4
now your knight is feeling the pressure
but also your rook is under attack here
Queen to c5 sauce all blacks problems
Queen captures Knight captures you get
the knight out of the way and black
simply keeps his extra pawn but for some
reason I ran off doesn't find this move
to be particularly interesting for him
rather he plays rook to d7 pinning the
knight on d4 but now it's a completely
different situation here Praga finds a
very nice move he plays g5 and now he
forces the knight to move that of course
the Queen cannot capture is this Queen
is guarding the g5 form but now it's a
different situation now you cannot
capture here because now Queen to e3 and
you no longer have f5 if f5 now then you
have G characters on f6 I'm Poisson and
there is no other point that can protect
the knight on e4 so it would be very
unfortunate here for black as you would
be losing a piece and on the other hand
after Queen to e3 if you try something
like rook see to d8 which is your only
option then you get c3 defending the
knight here and now after Queen captures
and g5 as there's really no better move
Queen captures here yes you are done
some pawns but you are up a piece and
you will most likely win this game as
white
so after this excellent move by Prabhu
g5 will have ninth to g4 by Ilan off and
okay Queen to g2 pressuring the night
once again knock fragra forces Queen
captures on g5 and now again this is all
very very much forcing from prag website
b5 a beautiful move that prevents f5 you
don't want to allow f5 to give this
night for the protection as he captures
on f6 and poisson is coming and also the
threat is rook to e4 and then winning
the night as you can't move the Queen
the Queen has to keep an eye on the
night and you can move the knight
because the Queen and g5 is undefended
so here are enough plays a really
beautiful move it on a plays Queen to f4
and it's it's a really beautiful
variation that shows why now rook to e4
is not playable so it's it's really an
interesting how I would put it it's
something you should really pause the
video here and try to see why rook to e4
doesn't work why it's good white White
Queen to f4 is such a beautiful move
because you will really feel good about
yourself so feel free to do it and you
know there's no why or what just feel
free to do it and then I will I will
show you why so for those of you who
figured it out congratulations you are
an excellent defender and for those who
just won't enjoy it show here rook to e4
isn't all that great because of knights
to e3 attacking the White Queen here and
after rook captures on f4 Knight
captures and g2 rook moves as the knight
is attacking the rook now okay it's not
all that impressive to find why this is
now playable but it seems like rook to
d2 will be a very unpleasant move for
this night as it doesn't really have all
that many squares to go to then you have
to see that rook to d5 is the move for
black and after rook to d2 attacking the
knight then black has this excellent f5
move that threatens the rook here and
after each captors on f6 now you have a
five and this is now very very beautiful
of course the night is now attacked
twice you can't move the night because
the rook on d2 is I'm unprotected so
after rook captures here you have route
captures here roped after spawn captors
and now if
- D - you have roped the c6 you're gonna
pick up this pawn and after rope
captures rook captures you have to be
careful or otherwise you're gonna be
checkmated here and h6 is a very weak
pawn black will most likely win it at
some point and enjoy a much better
endgame so here this is why Queen to f4
is such a beautiful move by a leonov but
brago doesn't bite he goes Knight to c6
the queen is guarding the night here and
he said brat well perhaps not a trap but
it's it's a very nice idea
he sets in motion Knights the e3 here
it's very interesting if you go rook D
to c7 which is also another option with
a double attack on this night then a
progress idea was in fact rook to e4 and
then after 9th to e3 rook captures on f4
Knight captures and g2 and now look
after d4 black will not be able to
capture the night because of another
checkmating sequence as the point is
still covering the g7 square so after
Knight to c6 we have Knights the e3 buy
enough and here fraggle plays the the
beautiful rook captures on d7 a very
nice Queen sacrifice Knight captures on
g2 and now comes the Knight to e7 check
King to f8 it doesn't matter King to f8
or King to hid and now Knight captures
on c8 and here is the point of this
Queen sacrifice the knight is covering
the e7 square and here black does not
have the time to capture here if Knight
captures then rope to the 8 will be
checkmate as bonus cos still covering g7
and the knight discovering the e7 square
so after Knight captures on c8 Queen
captures on h8 by a leonov we have
looked to f1 getting the rock uttered
way and also
pressuring the f7 Square and there's
really no way to defend it other than to
block the rock Knight to f4 is played
but now you can really see in how much
trouble of black is the queen is stuck
here guarding the knight on f4 of course
at some point black will push g5 but
still a very unpleasant position for
black nice to d6 pressuring the f7 pawn
we have g5 and now comes Knight captures
on f7 what an attack on the Queen Queen
to g7 and now comes Luke to D a check of
now if you captured an room d7 check
will win the Queen so I have to look to
the a check King to e7 and here we have
group 2a 8a threatening rook to a7 and
in this position power leonov decided to
play Queen captures on f7 he decided to
give back the Queen
but even if you play something like
Queen to g6 to get the Queen out of the
way out of the seventh rank then Knight
to d6 is coming and you can see that
this King really has no squares he can
go to then the knight rook and pawn are
really covering the King in ideas like
rook to d1 rook to e8 or coming and it
will be very unpleasant for the black
king so after rook to e8 e8 Iran decided
to play Queen captures on f7 but it
seems that out of the two evils this was
this was the greater one rook to e7
check we have King to f8 and now rook
captures on f7 King captures and now b3
preparing c4 now before seems like a
very nice move here for the on of the to
stop the advance of progress Queen side
pawns but he goes for h5 here he wants
to start pushing his own passport as
soon as possible and okay
Prager takes this opportunity he creates
a passed pawn on the Queen side we have
c4 me capture CB captures now a passed C
pawn has been created we have h4 and now
c5 we'll have to see who's passed pawn
is a faster pawn king to e7 and now rook
to d1 cutting off the King from the use
of the D file so of course this night
will block it at some point so the King
can approach the pawn but until then
first h3 further advancing his own
passed pawn
we have c6 Knight to the d5 now the King
can approach the passed pawn but this
was all progress plan here rook the g1
attacking the g5 pawn and now forcing h
2 h 2 is played and now rook to H 1 this
was all planned
Knight to be 4 and now we have c7
forcing the King to go further back
king 37 and now comes roof captures on
h2 King captures on h7 and now rook to
h6 are preparing to bring this rook
behind the past the G pawn king 37 and
now comes
rook to g6 we have a five and rook
captures on g5 so it's a rockin two
points against a knight and do pawns all
in all should be a winning game we have
King to c6 and now kink the b2 we have
King to d5 King to B 3 and now pink the
d4 if you try something like Knights the
d3 yes you will win this pawn but it
will not matter very much King today for
knife captures and now after King
captors and a 5 year too late to the
race you still have to move this night
for now the knight is pinned you have to
move the King then the night and then
only you can start pushing your phone
and you will be far too late white will
already start pushing Knight moves you
can attack the knight Knight moves and
now here and white will of course be
very much faster with his pawn and still
he has a rook against the night so
completely winning after King to b3 came
to d4 we have rook to h5 although
instead of this rook to h5 move you
could have considered something like a 3
but too damn nice to see 6 and it's not
all that clear how it can improve his
position so here Prague resides to waste
a move he plays rook to h5 and he waits
for black to either move his King or
denied and here Leonov does play Knight
to c6 and only that now the struggle go
King to a 4 and now again if you capture
here your knight will still be in the
way you will not be able to start
pushing your own past pawn so not really
something you want to do here we have
King to see for Bayern of trying to
close progress King in and now rook to
h6 at attacking the e6 pawn king to d5
now comes King the b5 and now we have
Knight captures on e5 finally rook
pinning the night we have King to d4
unpinning and now King captures on a5
King the d3 now comes King to b5 making
room to start pushing his own past pawn
and now e5 and out of starts pushing his
past bone as well
a4 we have a Knight to f4 attacking the
rook rook to h4 pinning the night King
the default on pinning a 5 we have
Knights to e6 and here after rook to c4
closing off the C file for Alana Brooke
it was in this position animal 64 that
Pavillion of this
I design the game so an excellent
victory for for American Honda in round
three of the 2018 Isle of Man
international tournament if you want you
can quickly see that if the pushing of
the pawn starts here for example a for a
63 a 7 e to a 8 check is coming a queen
is coming with check so there's really
nothing for black to do here mate is
assumed to follow so like I said after a
rope the c4 Adamo resigned and an
excellent victory for Ramage Bob
pregnant on de and here if you've been
following the Bobby Fischer series you
might remember I think it was around I
don't know somewhere in the second half
of the match
Miguel neither flew in from Buenos Aires
to Reykjavik and he he was interviewed
briefly and he said that one of the
things that was amazing about Bobby
Fischer was that he was different
compared to other grandmasters in a way
that others other grandmasters studied
how to win whereas Bobby Fischer
he studied why why a certain player lost
a certain game so he had he had
thousands of thousands of thousands of
these positions of why someone lost a
certain game in in his head and that
that's what made him a very different
player than anyone else and a lot more
dangerous than anyone else so here this
is one of the games that would be
excellent to check out move by move why
why alone of lost this game there are a
lot of reasons but if if you want to be
like Bobby Fischer you can take this
game and really really study why alone
of lost this game so I thought that'd be
you know a nice interesting thing to say
I do hope you enjoyed that and also a
brief announcement I will soon be
starting like a chess trivia or a chess
quiz on my Instagram profile so if you
enjoy a nice chess quiz or an ice chest
trivia like I don't know I still haven't
decided on the format perhaps once a
week 10 20 questions you know of some
interesting questions where you can
improve your vast knowledge on a weekly
basis and then perhaps one
bigger trivia for example once a month
then the first thing you will see in the
description below is a link to my
Instagram profile you know feel free to
follow that as well and you will you
know be able to get in on the action of
increasing your vast knowledge so yeah
now that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed that there will be a lot of
useful links in the description as well
like a link to the official page of the
iron chess they're all of their social
media profiles so feel free to check out
that as well I would like to thank
Joseph order Jeffery cook
show me a bourbon Kaitlyn Stanton and
Peterman order Matt for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check do
all my previous videos here thank all
for watching and I'll see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content
see you soon